The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation, or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
JEREMY KEPNER: All right,
so we're doing lecture 06
in the course today.
That's in the-- just
remind people it's
in the docs directory here.
And I'm going to be
doing a lot, talking
about a particular application,
which I think is actually
representative of a
variety of applications
that we do a lot of things,
similar statistical properties
of a sequence cross correlation.
OK.
So diving right in.
Just going to give
an introduction
to this particular problem
of genetic sequence analysis
from a computational perspective
and how the D4M technology can
really make it pretty easy
to do the kinds of things
that people like to do.
And then just talk
about the pipeline
that we implemented to implement
this system because, as I've
said before, when you're dealing
with this type of large data,
the D4M technology is one piece.
It's often the piece you use
to prototype your algorithms.
But to be a part of
a system, you usually
have to stitch together a
variety of technologies,
databases obviously being
an important part of that.
So this is a great chart.
This is the relative cost
per DNA sequence over time
here, over the last 20 years.
So we're getting a
little cut off here
at the bottom of the screen.
So I think I'm-- hmm.
So you know, this just
shows Moore's law,
so we all know that that
technology has been increasing
at an incredible rate.
And as we've seen, the
cost of DNA sequencing
is going down dramatically.
So the first DNA
sequence, people nominally
say to sequence the
first human genome
was around a billion dollars.
And they're expecting it to be
$100 within the next few years.
So having your
DNA sequenced will
become probably a fairly
routine medical activity
in the next decade.
And so the data
generated, you know,
typically a human genome
will have billions
of DNA sequences in it.
And that's a lot of data.
What's actually perhaps
even more interesting
than sequencing your
DNA is sequencing
the DNA of all the
other things that
are in you, which is sometimes
called the metagenome.
So take a swab and
not just get the DNA--
your DNA, but also of
all the other things that
are a part of you, which can be
ten times larger than your DNA.
So depending on
that, so they now
have developed these
high volume sequencers.
Here's an example of one
that I believe can do 600.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
JEREMY KEPNER: OK.
No problem.
That 600 billion
base pairs a day,
so like 600 gigabytes
of data a day.
And this is all data that
you want to cross correlate.
I mean, it's your--
it's a-- so that's
what this-- this is a table
top, a table top apparatus here
that sells for a few
hundred thousand dollars.
And they are even getting
into portable sequencers
that you can plug in
with a USB connection
into a laptop or
something like that.
It-- to do more in the
field types of things.
So why would you
want to do this?
I think abstractly to understand
all that would be good.
Computation plays a huge role
because this data is collected.
And it's just sort of abstract
snippets of DNA, you know?
Just even assembling them
into a-- just your DNA
into a whole process can take
a fair amount of computation.
And right now, that is
actually something that
takes a fair amount of time.
And so to give you an example,
here's a great use case.
This shows, if you recall,
in the summer of 2011
there was a virulent E.
coli outbreak in Germany.
And not to single
out the Germans.
We've certainly
had the same things
occur in the United States.
And these occur all
across the world.
And so, you know, this shows
kind of the time course in May.
You know, the first
cases starting appear.
And then those lead
to the first deaths.
And then it spikes.
And then that's
just kind of when
you hit this peak is when they
really identify the outbreak.
And then they
finally figured out
what the-- what it is
that's causing people
and begin to remediate it.
But, you know, until you kind
of really have this portion,
people are still getting
exposed to the thing, usually
before they actually
nail it down.
There's lots of
rumors flying around.
All other parts of the
food chain are disrupted.
You know, any single
time a particular product
is implicated, that's
hundreds of millions
of dollars of lost
business as people just
basically-- you know,
they say it's spinach.
Then everyone stops buying
spinach for a while.
And, oh, it wasn't spinach.
Sorry.
It was something else.
And so that's-- so
there's a dual-- you know,
so they started by implicating
this, the cucumbers,
but that wasn't quite right.
They've then
sequenced the stuff.
And then they correctly
identified it was the sprouts.
At least I believe that was
the time course of events here.
So-- and this is sort of the
integrated number of deaths.
And so, you know, the
story here is obviously
the thing we want to do most
is when a person gets sick
here or here, wouldn't it
be great to sequence them
immediately, get
that information,
know exactly what's
causing the problem,
and then be able to start
testing the food supply channel
so that you can make a real
impact on the mortality?
And then likewise, not
have the economic--
you know, obviously
the loss of life
is the preeminent issue here.
But there's also
the economic impact,
which certainly the people
who are in those businesses
would want to address.
So as you can see,
there was a really sort
of a rather long delay
here between sort
of when the outbreak started
and the DNA sequence released.
And this was actually a big
step forward in the sense
that DNA sequencing
really did play-- ended up
playing a role in this
process as opposed
to previously where
it may not have.
And in the-- and
people see that now
and they would love
to move this earlier.
So, you know, and
obviously in our business
and across, it's not just
this type of example.
But there's other
types of examples
where rapid sequencing
and identification would
be very important.
And there are
certainly investments
being made to try and
make that more possible.
So an example of what the
processing timeline looks
now, I mean, you're
basically starting
with the human infection.
And it could be a
natural disease.
Obviously in the DOD, they're
very concerned about bioweapons
as well.
So there's the collection of
the sample, the preparation,
the analysis, and sort
of the overall time
to actionable data.
And really, it's not to say
processing plays everything
on this, but if you, as
part of a whole system,
you could imagine if you
could do on-site collection,
automatic preparation, and
then very quick analysis,
you could imagine
shorting this cycle down
to one day, which would be
something that would really
make a huge impact.
Some of the other useful
sequences, useful-- I'm sorry,
roles for DNA sequence matching
is quickly comparing two data--
two sets of DNA.
Identification,
that is, who is it?
Analysis of mixtures, you
know, what type of things
could you determine if someone
was related to somebody else?
Ancestry analysis,
which can be used
in disease outbreaks,
criminal investigation,
and personal medicine.
You know, the set of things
is pretty large here.
So I'm not going to explain to
you kind of fundamentally what
is the algorithm that we
use for doing this matching,
but we're going to explain it
in terms of the mathematics
that we've described
before, which
is these associative
arrays, which actually
make it very, very easy to
describe what's going on here.
If I was to describe to you the
traditional approaches for how
we describe DNA
sequence matching,
it would actually
be-- that would
be a whole lecture in itself.
So let me get into
that algorithm.
And so basically this is it.
On one slide is how we do
DNA sequencing matching.
So we have a reference
sequence here.
This is something that
we know, a database
of data that we know.
And it consists of a sequence
ID and then a whole bunch
of what are called base pairs.
And this can usually be
several hundred long.
And you'll have
thousands of these,
each that are a few hundred,
maybe 1,000 base pairs long.
And so the standard approach to
this is to take these sequences
and break them up into
smaller units, which
are called words or mers.
And a standard number
is called a 10mer.
So they're basically--
what you would
say is you take the first
ten letters, and you say,
"All right.
That's one 10mer."
Then you move it
over one, and you
say that's another 10mer,
and so on and so forth.
So you had, if this was
a sequence of 400 long,
you would have 400 10mers, OK?
And then you're obviously
multiplying the total data
volume by a factor of ten
because of this thing.
And so for those of us who
know signal processing,
this is just standard filtering.
Nothing new here.
Very, very standard type
of filtering approach.
So then what we do is
for each sequence ID, OK,
this forms the row key
of an associative array.
And each 10mer of
that sequence forms
a column key of that 10mer.
So you can see here
each of these rows
shows you all the unique 10mers
that appeared in that sequence.
And then a column is
a particular 10mer.
So as we can see, certain
10mers appear very commonly.
And some appear in
a not so common way.
So that gives us an
associative array,
which is a sparse matrix where
we have sequence ID by 10mer.
And then we do the same
thing with the collection.
So we've collected, in this
case, some unknown bacteria
sample.
And we have a similar
set of sequences here.
And we do the exact same thing.
We have a sequence ID
and then the 10mer.
And then what we want to
do is cross correlate,
find all the matches
between them.
And so that's just done
with matrix multiply.
So A1 transpose A2
will then result
in a new matrix, which
is reference sequence
ID by unknown sequence ID.
And then it will then--
the value in here
will be how many
matches they had.
And so generally you look,
if say, 400 was the match,
then you would be looking for
things well above 30 or 40
matches between them.
Or our true match would be maybe
50%, 60%, 70% of them match.
And so then you can just
apply a threshold to this
to deter-- to find the
true, true matches.
So very simple.
And, you know, there are large
software packages out there
that do this.
They essentially
do this algorithm
with various twists and
variations and stuff like that.
But here we can
explain the whole thing
knowing the mathematics
of associative arrays
on one slide.
So this calculation is
what we call a direct match
calculation.
We're literally comparing
every single sequence's 10mers
with all the other ones.
And this is essentially what
sequence comparison does.
And it takes a lot of
computation to do this.
If you might have millions
of sequence IDs and millions
of sequence IDs,
this very quickly
becomes a large amount
of computational effort.
So we are, of course, interested
in other techniques that
could possibly accelerate this.
So one of the things we're
able to do using the Accumulo
database is ingest
this entire set
of data as an associative
array into the database.
And using Accumulo's tally
features, then tally.
Have it essentially,
as we do the ingestion,
automatically tally the
counts for each 10mer.
So we can then
essentially construct
a histogram of all the 10mers.
Some 10mers will appear in a
very large number of sequences,
and some 10mers will
appear in not very many.
So this is that
histogram, or essentially
a degree distribution.
We talked about degree
distributions in other.
This tells us that
there's one 10mer that
appears in, you know, 80%
or 90% of all the sequences.
And then there's 20 or 30 10mers
that appear in just a few.
And then there's a distribution,
as in this case, almost a law--
of sort of almost a
log normal curve that
shows you that really,
most of the 10mers
seem to have-- appear in
a few hundred sequences.
And so now one
thing I've done here
is create certain thresholds
to say, all right.
If I only wanted-- if I looked
at that large, sparse matrix
of the data, and I wanted to
threshold, what-- how many--
how much of the data
would I eliminate?
So if I wanted to
eliminate 50% of the data,
I could set a
threshold, let's only
look at things that are less
than a degree of 10,000.
You might say, well, why would
I want to eliminate these very,
very popular things?
Well because they
appear everywhere,
a true match is--
they're not going
to give me any information
that really tells me
about true matches.
Those are going to be clutter.
Everything has them.
That two sequences share that
particular 10mer doesn't really
give me a lot of power in
selecting which one it really
belongs to.
So like-- so I can do that.
If I wanted to go down to only
5% of the data, I could say,
you know, I only want to
look at 10mers that are 100,
you know, or that have--
that appear in 100
of these sequences or less.
And if I wanted to go
even further, you know,
I could go down to
is 20, 30, 40, 50,
and I would only have one
half percent of the data.
I would have eliminated
from consideration 99.5%
of the data.
So and then if I
can do that, then
that's very powerful because I
can quickly take my sample data
set.
I know all the 10mers it has.
And I can quickly look it
up against this histogram
and say, "No.
I don't want to do any.
I only care about this
very small section of data,
and I only need to do
correlations from that."
So let's see how that works out.
And I should say, this
technique is very generic.
You could do it
for text matching.
If you have documents,
you have the same issue.
Very popular words are not going
to tell you really anything
meaningful about whether
two documents are
related to each other.
It's going to be clutter.
And other types of records
of that thing, you know?
So in the graph
theory perspective,
we call these super nodes.
These 10mers are super nodes.
They have connections
to many, many things,
and therefore, if you try
and connect through them,
it's just going to not give
you very useful information.
You know, it's like
people visiting Google.
Looking for all the records
where people connect--
visited Google is
not really going
to tell you much unless
you have more information.
And so it's not a very
big distinguishing factor.
So here's an example
of the results
of doing-- of selecting
this low threshold,
eliminating 99.5% of the data,
and then comparing our matches
that we got with
what happens when
we've used 100% of the data.
And so what we have here is
the true 10mer match and then
the measured
sub-sampled match here.
And what you see here is that
we get a very, very high success
rate in terms of we basically
detect all strong matches using
only half percent of the data.
And, you know, the
number of false positives
is extremely low.
In fact, a better
way to look at that
is if we look at the cumular--
cumulative probability
of detection.
This shows this that if
the actual match, if there
was actually 100 matches
between two sequences,
we detect all of those
using only 1/20 of the data.
And likewise, in our
probability false alarm rate,
we see that if you see
more than a match of ten
in the sub-sample data, that
is going to be a true match
essentially 100% of the time.
And so this technique allows
us to dramatically speed up
the rate at which we can
do these comparisons.
And you do have the
price to pay that you
have to pre-load
your reference data
into this special database.
But since you tend
to be more concerned
about comparing
with respect to it,
that is a worthwhile investment.
So that's just an example of how
you can use these techniques,
use the mathematics
of associative arrays,
and these databases
together in a coherent way.
So we can do more
than just find.
So the matrix
multiply I showed you
before, A1 times A2
transposed showed us
the counts, the
number of matches.
But sometimes we don't want
to know more than that.
We want to know not just
the number of matches,
but please show me the
exact set of 10mers
that caused the match, OK?
And so this is
where, and I think
we talked about this
in a previous lecture,
we have these special matrix
multiplies that will actually
take the intersecting key in
the matrix and multiply it now,
assign that to the value
field or [INAUDIBLE].
And so that's why we
have the special matrix
multiply called CatKeyMul.
And so, for instance
here, if we look
at the result of that,
which is AK, and we say,
"Show me all the value matches
that are greater than six
in their rows and their
columns together,"
now we can see that
this sequence ID
matched with this sequence ID.
And these were the actual
10mers that generated
that they had in common.
Now clearly six is
not a true match
in this little sample data set.
We don't have any true matches.
But this just shows
you what that is like.
And so this is what we
call a pedigree preserving
correlation.
That is, it shows you
the-- it doesn't just
give you the count.
It shows you where that
evidence came from.
And you can track it back.
And this is something we
do want to do all the time.
If you imagined two
documents that you
wanted to cross correlate,
you might say, all right.
I have these two
documents, and now I've
cross correlated
their word matches.
Well, now I want to know the
actual words that matched,
not just the counts.
And you would use the exact
same multiply to do that.
Likewise, you could do
the word/word correlation
of a document.
So that would be
A transpose times
A instead of A, A transpose.
And then it would
show you two words.
It would show you
the list of documents
that they actually
had in common.
So again, this is a
powerful-- a powerful tool.
Again, I should remind
people when using this,
you do have to be careful
when you do, say, CatKeyMul A1
times A1 transpose if you do
a square because you will then
end up with this
very dense diagonal,
and these lists will
get extremely long.
And you can often run out
of memory when that happens.
So you do have to be careful
when you do correlations,
these CatKeyMul
correlations on things
that are going to have very
large, overlapping matches.
The regular matrix
multiply, you don't
have to worry about
that, creating dense.
You know, that's not a problem.
But that's just a little
caveat to be aware of.
And there's really
nothing we can do about
that if you do square
them, you know?
And we've thought about
creating a new function, which
is basically squaring
with and basically
not doing the diagonal.
And we may end up making that
if we can figure that one out.
So once you have those
actual specific matches here,
so for example, we have
our two reference samples.
And we looked at the
ones that were larger.
So here's our two sequences.
This, if we look back at the
original data, which actually
stored the locations of that.
So now we're saying,
oh, these two
have six matches between them.
Let me look them up through
this one line statement here.
Now I can see the
actual 10mers that match
and their actual locations
in the real data.
And from that, I can then deduce
that, oh, actually this is not
six separate 10mer
matches, but it's really
two sort of-- what is this,
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9, 10.
One 10mer match,
and then I guess--
I think this is like
a 17 match, right?
And likewise over here.
You get a similar type of thing.
So that's basically
stitching it back
together because that's
really what you're
trying to do is find these
longer sequences where
it's identical.
And then people
can then use those
to determine functionality
and other types of things
that have to do with that.
So this is just part of
the process of doing that.
And it just shows by having
this pedigree-preserving matrix
multiply and the ability
to store string values
in the value, that we
can actually preserve
that information and do that.
So that just shows you, I
think, a really great example.
It's kind of one of
the most recent things
we did this summer in terms
of the power of D4M coupled
with databases to really do
algorithms that are completely
kind of new and interesting.
And as algorithm
developers, I think
that's something that we
are all very excited about.
So now I'm going to
talk about how this
fits into an overall pipeline.
So once again,
just for reminders,
you know, D4M, we've talked
mostly about working over here
in this space, in
the Matlab space,
for doing your analytics
with associative arrays.
But they also have ways-- we
have very nice bindings too.
In particular, the
Accumulo database,
but we can bind to just
about any database.
And here's an example.
If I have a table that
shows all this data,
and I just wanted to
get, please give me
the column of this
10mer sequence,
I would just type that
query and it would return
that column for me very nicely.
So it's a very powerful
binding to databases.
It's funny because a lot of
people, when I talk to them,
are like-- they think
D4M is either just about
databases or just about this
associative array mathematics.
And because they usually kind
of-- people take sort of--
they usually see it sort of more
used in one context or another.
And it's really about both.
It's really about connecting
the two worlds together.
That particular application
that we showed you,
this genetic sequence
comparison application
is like you-- is a
part of a pipeline,
like you would see
in any real system.
And so I'm going to show
you that pipeline here.
And so we have
here the raw data.
So Fasta is just the
name of the file format
that all of this DNA
sequence comes in,
which basically looks
pretty much like a CSV
file of what I just saw you.
I guess that deserves a name as
a file format, but, you know.
So it's basically that.
And then one thing we do is we
parse that data from the Fasta
data into a triples
format, which
allows us to then really work
it with this associative array.
So it basically
creates the 10mers
and puts them into a
series of triple files,
or a row triple file,
which holds the sequence
ID, the actual 10mer
itself, a list of those,
and then the position of
where that 10mer appeared
in the sequence.
And then typically
what we do then
is we read-- we write a program.
And this can be a
parallel program
if we want it that will
then, usually in Matlab
using D4, that will
read these sequences in
and will often just
directly insert them
without any
additional formatting.
Just-- we have a way of just
inserting triples directly
into the Accumulo database,
and which is the fastest way
that we can do inserts.
And then it will also convert
these to associative arrays
in Matlab and will save
them out as mat files
because this will take
a little time to convert
all of these things into files.
You're like, well
why would we do that?
Well, there's two very good
reasons for doing that.
One, the Accumulo
database, or any database,
is very good if
we want to look up
a small part of a
large data set, OK?
So if we have
billions of records,
and we want millions
of those records,
that's a great
use of a database.
However, there are certain
times we're like, no.
We want to traverse
the entire data set.
Well, databases are
actually bad at doing that.
If you say, "I want to scan
over the entire database,"
it's like doing a billion
queries, you know?
And so there's overheads
associated with that.
In that instance, it's far more
efficient to just save the data
into these associative
array files, which
will read in very quickly.
And then you can
just-- if you're like,
"I want to do an
analysis of the data
in that way where I'm going to
want-- I really want to work
with 10% or 20% of the data."
Then having these-- this
data in this already parsed
into this binary format,
is a very efficient way
to run an application or an
analytic that will run over
all of those files.
It also makes
parallelism very easily.
You just get-- let
different processors
process different files.
You know that's very easy to do.
We have lots of support
for that type of model.
And so that's a good
reason to do that.
And at worst, you're
doubling the size
of the data and your database.
Don't worry about it.
We double data and
databases all the time.
Databases are
notoriously, if you
put a certain amount of data
in, they make it much larger.
Accumulo actually does
a very good job of that.
It won't really be
that much larger.
But there's no reason to not,
as you're doing the ingest,
to save those files.
And then you can do
various comparisons.
So for example, we
then can-- if this--
if we save the sample
data as a Matlab file, we
could read that in.
And then do our comparison
with the reference data
that's sitting
inside the database
to get our top matches.
And that's exactly how this
application actually works.
So this pipeline from raw
data to an intermediate format
to a sort of efficient
binary format and insertion
to then doing the
analytics and comparisons.
And eventually,
you'll usually often
have another layer, which
is you might create a web
interface to something.
We're like, OK.
This is now a full system.
A person can type in your--
or put in their own data.
And then it will
then call a function.
So again, this is very standard
how this stuff ends up fitting
into an overall pipeline.
And it's certainly
a situation where
if you're going to deploy
a system, you might decide,
you know what?
I don't want Matlab to be a
part of my deployed system.
I want to do that, say, in
Java or something else that's
sort of more universal, which
we certainly see people do.
It still makes sense to
do it in this approach
because the algorithm
development in testing
is just much, much easier to
do in an environment like D4M.
And then once you have
the algorithm correct,
it's now much
easier to give that
to someone else
who is going to do
the implementation in
another environment and deal
with all the issues that are
associated with maybe doing
a deployment type of thing.
So one certainly could use the
Matlab or the new octave code
in a production environment.
We certainly have seen that.
But often the case,
one has limitations
about what can deploy.
And so it is still better to
do the algorithm development
in this type of environment
than to try and do
the algorithm in a deployment
language like Java.
One of the things that was very
important for this database,
and it's true of most
parallel databases.
So if we want to get the
highest performance insert, that
is, we want to read
the data and insert it
as quickly as possible
in the database,
typically we'll need to have
some kind of parallel program
running, in this case,
maybe each reading
different sets of input
files and all inserting them
into the parallel database.
And so in Accumulo,
they divide your table
amongst the different computers,
which they call tablet servers.
And it's very important
to avoid the situation
where everyone is
inserting and all the data
is inserting into the
same tablet server.
You're not going to get
really very good performance.
Now, the way Accumulo
splits up its data
is similar to many
other databases.
It's called sharting,
sometimes they call it.
It just means they
split up the table,
but the term, in the
database community,
uses-- they call it sharting.
What they'll do is they'll
basically take the table
and they'll assign certain row
keys, in this c-- in Accumulo's
case, certain contiguous
sets of row keys
to particular tablet servers.
So, you know, if you had a
data set that was universally
split over the alphabet, then--
and you were going to split it,
the first split would
be between m and n.
And so this is called splitting.
And it's very important
to try and get good splits
and choose your splits so
that you get good performance.
Now D4M has a native interface
that allows you to just say,
here are the-- I want these to
be the splits of this table.
You can actually compute
those and assign them
if you have a parallel instance.
In the class, you will only be
working on the databases that
will be set up for you.
We have set up for you are
all single node instances.
They do not have
multiple tablet servers,
so you don't really have to
do-- deal with splitting.
It's only an issue
in parallel, but it's
certainly something to be
aware of and is often the key.
People will often have a
very large Accumulo instance.
And they may only be getting
not very-- the performance
they would get on-- in just
a two node instance because--
and usually it's because
their splitting needs
to be done in this proper way.
And this is true of all
databases, not just Accumulo.
But other databases have
the exact same issue.
Accumulo is called Accumulo
because it has something called
accumulators, which
is what actually makes
this whole bioinformatics
application really go,
which is that I can
denote a column in a table
to be an accumulator
column, which
means whenever a
new entry is hit,
some action will be performed.
In this case, the
default is addition.
And so a standard thing
we'll do in our schema,
as we've already
talked about these
exploded transpose pair
schemas that allows
do fast lookups in
rows and columns
is we'll, OK, create two
additional tables, one of which
holds the sums of the
rows, and one of which
holds the sums of the columns
which then allows us to do
these very fast lookups of
the statistics, which is very
useful to know how do we avoid
accidentally looking up columns
that will have-- that are
present in the whole database.
An issue that
happens all the time
is that you'll have a
column, and it's essentially
almost a dense column in the
database, and you really,
really, really don't
want to look that up
because it's basically giving
you the whole database.
Well, with this accumulator, you
can look up the column first,
and it will give you a
count and be like, oh, yeah.
And then you can just say, no.
I want to look up
everything but that column.
So very powerful, very
powerful tool for doing that.
That's also another
reason why we construct
the associative array
when we load it for insert
because when we construct
the associative array,
we can actually do a quick
sum right then and there
of whatever piece we've read in.
And so then when we send
that into the database,
we've dramatically reduced
the number of-- the amount
of tallying it has to do.
And this can be
a huge time saver
because if you don't do that,
you're essentially reinserting
the data two more times
because, you know,
when you've inserted it into
the table and it's transpose,
and to get the
accumulation effect,
you would have to
directly insert it.
But if we can do a
pre-sum, that reduces
the amount of work on that
accumulator table dramatically.
And so again, that's another
reason why we do that.
So let's just talk about some
of the results that we see.
So here's an example
on a-- let's see,
this is an eight node database.
And this shows us
the ingest rate
that we get using different
numbers of ingesters.
So this is different
programs all
trying to insert into this
database simultaneously.
And this just shows the
difference between having 0
splits and, in this case, 35
splits was the optimal number
that we had.
And you see, it's a
rather large difference.
And you don't get--
you get some benefit
with multiple inserters,
but that sort of ends
when you don't do this.
So this is just an example
of why you want to do that.
Another example is with the
actual human DNA database.
This shows us our insert
rate on doing-- using
different numbers of inserters.
And yeah, so this is
eight tablet servers.
And this just shows the
different number of ingesters
here.
And since we're doing
proper splitting,
we're getting very nice scaling.
And this is actually the
actual output from Accumulo.
It actually has a
nice little meter here
that shows you what it says
you're actually getting,
which is very, very nice
to be able to verify
that you and the
database both agree
that your insert rate is--
so this is insert right here.
So you see, we're getting
about 4,000-- 400,000 entries
per second, which is an
extraordinarily high number
in the database community.
Just to give you
a comparison, it
would not be
uncommon if you were
to set up a MySQL instance
on a single computer
and have one inserter going into
it to get maybe 1,000 inserts
per second on a good day.
And so, you know,
this is essentially
the core reason why
people use Accumulo
is because of this very high
insert and query performance.
And this just shows our
extrapolated run time.
If we wanted to, for instance,
ingest the entire human Fasta
database here of
4.5 billion entries,
we could do that in
eight hours, which
would be a very reasonable
amount of time to do that.
So in summary, what
we are able to achieve
with this application is this
shows one of these diagrams.
I think I showed one
in the first lecture.
This is a way of sort of
measuring our productivity
and our performance.
So this shows the volume
of code that we wrote.
And this shows the run time.
So obviously this
is better down here.
And this shows BLAST.
So BLAST is the industry
standard application
for doing sequence match.
And I don't want, in any
way, to say that we are
doing everything BLAST does.
BLAST is almost a
million lines of code.
It does lots and lots
of different things.
It handles all different
types of file formats
and little nuances and
other types of things.
But at its core, it
does what we did.
And we were able to basically
do that in, you know,
150 lines of D4M code.
And using the database,
we were able to do
that 100 times faster.
And so this is really the
power of this technology
is to allow you to
develop these algorithms
and implement them
and, in this case,
actually leverage the database
to essentially replace lookups
with computations in a
very intelligent way,
in a way that's knowledgeable
about the statistics
of your data.
And that's really the power.
And these are the types of
results that people can get.
And this whole result was done
with one summer student, a very
smart summer
student, but we were
able to put this whole system
together in about a couple
of months.
And this is from a person who
knew nothing about Accumulo
or D4M or anything like that.
They were a good--
they were smart.
They were good, solid Java
background and very energetic.
But, you know,
these are the kinds
of things we've
been able to see.
So just to summarize,
we, again, we
see-- I think just to--
this types of techniques
are useful for document analysis
and network analysis and DNA
sequencing.
You know, this is
really summarizing
all the applications
that we've talked about.
We think there's a pretty big
gap between doing the data
analysis tools that our really
algorithm developers need.
And we think D4M
is really allowing
us to use a tool like Matlab
for its traditional role
in this new domain, which
is algorithm development.
Figure things out,
getting things right
before you can then hand it on
to someone else to implement
and actually get enough
production environment.
So with that, that brings
the end to the lecture.
And then there's
some examples where
we show you the-- this stuff.
So-- and there's
no homework other
than I sent you all
that link to see
if your access to
the database exists.
Did everyone-- raise your hand.
Did you check the link out?
Yes?
You logged in?
It worked?
You saw a bunch of
databases there?
OK.
If it doesn't work,
because the next class is
sort of the
penultimate class, I'm
going to go through
all these examples.
And the assignment will
be to run those examples
on those databases.
So you will be really using
D4M, touching a database,
doing real analytics, doing
very complicated things.
The whole class is just going
to be a demonstration of that.
Everything we've been
doing has been leading up.
So the concepts are in place
so that you can understand
those examples fairly easily.
All right, so we will
take a short break here.
And then we will come
back, and I will show
you the demo, this week's demo.